remember back when Apple introduced the
unbelievably thin MacBook Air by pulling
it out of the manila envelope here's the
next chapter to that story this is the
new MacBook it is unbelievably
ridiculously I poppin leaf it but with
intel's entry-level Core M processor it
places more focus on portability than on
power it's also crazy expensive starting
at twelve hundred ninety nine dollars
that price for what is let's face it a
netbook has led some people to mock
Apple for releasing essentially two
vespa of laptops this is a luxury
machine a fancy toy for people who like
fancy toys but with this new MacBook
Apple is also making a couple of huge
bets on the future of the PC for one
thing that it's going to be Wireless the
MacBook has only a single USBC port and
a headphone jack the PC of the future is
also apparently going to be smaller the
screen and bezels are a little shrunk
from the standard 13-inch MacBook Air
which means Apple could fit a 12-inch
display into a really small body it's
only a half inch thick at its biggest
point and less than a quarter inch at
the front of the wedge-shaped machine it
weighs just a hair over two pounds and
it feels almost impossible that a laptop
could be this light I can't recommend
this MacBook to everyone yet it's for a
certain user in a certain tax bracket
with certain power needs and I mean come
on it comes in gold and silver and Space
Gray but this is a signal of what Apple
thinks is the future of the PC that
first air came out and everyone went
nuts over the missing optical drive or
the lack of firewire but over time Apple
was proven right and if Apple's right
again and I suspect it is we're not far
from the next generation of pcs we're
ports and docks will be replaced by
cloud storage and wireless devices and
that is really good news